Hi. Goal for right
now do a bit of analysis on some Perf
stuff. Not spend the whole day on it.
Just like check on some things real
quick. And
um yeah, we will go from from here
because there's like a lot of small
stuff we got to do to prepare for the
release.
Um all right, let's try one thing. I
wanted to look at
%. Okay, there's still 10% copy
overhead.
15%. So, it's like 3x faster, but
there's
still 15% copy overhead for something
that should totally not have that.
All
right. So, here's the uh the question,
right? I don't know. Let's ask Brock
first just to see if I'm missing
anything obvious and then we'll go to
more more things thereafter.
Um 10%
Nah, there's no way that it's down this
bad, right?
tensor?
No, it
into memory would avoid a staging copy.
Yeah, I saw like 3x
still 8.6
GB. That's like Yeah. Crazy low. So,
that's what I'm getting as well.
So, I mean, this is bizarre, right?
Like we have a performance now that's
like a hundth of what we're supposed to
be
getting. Either of those are going to be
very slow.
of wait see transfer
rates 20 to 50 gigabytes.
One? That seems like suspicious,
right? Like there's no way. It's like we
would notice a way bigger
difference. Hang on. Let me see if I try
this on
my my
local current is four. Okay. Wait, no.
This is
mil 15%
copy and this runs 7
mil with 8% or no 12%
copy. Yeah. So I don't know what's up
with the PCIe. That reporting must be
wrong.
Because yeah, this does not get
better. And why is the end of
20 21%
I must be
um misreading this.
PCIe. So, the 1.8 terabytes is card to
card, I
guess. Wait, what is the 1.8?
memory. Okay. So, I'm just I've read
this completely wrong.
the max
PCIe should be
32. I would have expected that to be way
more than that.
So now we are kind of at a place where
where this does matter.
you make like these raw
arrays. Was it selfshared memory?
three. There's no way to pin this thing,
I think.
this with the native back end only.
But then I wouldn't be multi-processed,
which is rough.
uh
three was it three or four gigabytes a
second but then it's not in pinned
memory so you have a copy
Okay. Hang on. Well, there are a few
there are a few things actually here
that are really weird, right?
There are like multiple things here that
don't add up.
all, there should not be any substantial
end of
overhead. Oh, wait. Actually, I know
what it is. I know what this is. I left
a setting.
args. Unless I built it with an old
version.
million. Uh, this used to be
faster. I'm pretty dang sure.
Okay. So, this is the
expected number
here. And I thought breakout was this
fast as well.
Okay. So, this is what I thought,
right? You
see here we have 50
million 50 million steps per second.
But we should not be
getting way less than
that in the
There's like no other
jank args that I could
see unless if it had like have sanitiz
in it or something that would screw it
up. But I thought that
building and look at the args that it
was built
with dcc with
O2 some includes
It's this has the binding file. I don't
think it's caching.
It can't be caching the sea source,
It's like when you call vex step,
right? You're not actually like taking
any args. This is just a
pointer. And then you call Cstep on
this. Like it already has the references
to everything in
memory. So there should be literally no
opportunity for any overhead whatsoever
here. But I don't know how it is that
it's 10x
slower in the Python than it is in the C
when it's that thin of a
wrapper. I mean, let's just try a couple
things.
Just some
slower. Yeah. And that is substantially
slower. Like really slow
4096, you know, it's saturated, so it's
not going to get any better than 7
mil from this
this. Okay. 9 mil. So there is some
overhead with this but
like it is actually the step function.
Like if I just comment the step function
out,
right? Oh, wait. I wonder if it's
logging. Hang on. It's probably logging,
right? I might feel really dumb if that
was what it is.
If I just comment all this, we're just
stepping the
environment. There's no like weird
Python shenanigans going on down there,
right?
What would be causing
that? It's like
Yeah. I mean, I did just autocomplete
that really quick. I was mostly going
off the fact that um I've run these
before and it was like similar perf to
pong. Also, intuitively like breakout
shouldn't be really much slower than
pong,
right? I guess it depends how it's
implemented. I forget if it checks every
brick or
not. Oh, wait. Why did this put
23? This just made up a number.
Hang
23. I I don't know if that can do
anything though.
Okay. So now it should be definitely
correct, right?
One of these two tests is wrong,
right? Or there's like some weird
overhead. The thing that's weird is that
I get this with uh with breakout, right?
If I run the test on
breakout or I mean on
pong. I should probably copy this demo
to pong. Huh?
N. That's not the signature for Pong.
One bit.
Okay. So, this
says 50
million. It's a bit suspicious if it's
like showing as faster in
um
in Python.
Well, it is using a different
compiler but
So there is a big compiler
difference. It's actually it's slower
though with
GCC. So it's a bit suspicious I suppose
then that
um it is faster in
Python. I don't see how I could have
done it wrong, though.
Oh well, this is also calling time in a
loop, I
rand. Both of these things are batched
in the Python one.
Does it make sense that breakout should
be that
Oh, it's actually kind of suspicious
then, isn't it? Because
like this is doing naively. It's like
naively checking every single brick, I'm
pretty sure.
man. No, actually it's
not. It's actually It's smartly like
checking only local collisions. So, in
that case, then yeah, they should be
able to be quite fast.
I've forgotten about that. The original
wasn't that smart, but the this version
actually it makes sense that this should
not be substantially slower than
because I'm trying to think like
realistically what we could get done
today. I mean, unless there's just some
like screw up
here. I don't see how I would be
screwing up.
right? Does the overhead still not make
sense? Even if it is 7
million. I guess it kind of depends. No,
that actually could make sense.
Let's just do a few other like let's not
get too too hung up on
this because like realistically we're
just kind of looking for anything that
we might have missed that's quick to
find for this release. Like we're going
to have all the time in the world after
the release to do uh more stuff on this.
huh? If we want to like really test what
we can we can push here.
Here probably we need to do this as
well.
I'm just trying to see how fast like
theoretically we can actually get this
stuff to run like an ideal case. Okay,
so that doesn't
like it doesn't like that one bit. Cool.
Good to know.
Uh yeah, this has completely killed my
my terminal.
mil. Okay. 63% on
learn and then with breakout wasn't it
learn. Something's got to be different
between these two. Oh, max mini batch
size. Duh.
mil. Yeah.
Okay. What if reinforcement learning at
15 million steps per second?
I mean,
realistically, all we would need is to
be able to actually learn from these
giant
batches. M is at
2%. Copy is at 11.
I think they're the TF32 tensor
cores. What you would want
I'm trying to think if there's anything
we can actually take out of this. Right.
Like technically I know how we set all
these parameters. It's a little tricky
though. I mean Boxon should be here any
second, right? So we can chat with him
for a bit and then uh figure this out
after.
If I just do something ridiculous
like if I let you take 500 million steps
per second per
pong, can you actually get anything
useful out of
Um, that is actually solving it.
What? Wait.
So, can we just say like completely
screw it and just
do like
This is not even me like just playing a
prank and using a really dumb network
either. Like I can do this if I want to
be really stupid, right? I can do this
and just like make it a trivial little
this. Okay. If I want to just like be
totally
silly like there's 20 million, right?
Like that's with a dumb network. That
doesn't make any
sense. It's still kind of solving
slowly, isn't it?
solving. Can I do like this and have it
dissolve?
The only thing practical I can take from
this I guess is
that we should sweep higher mini batch
sizes. Let me actually play with neural
MMO 3 until box here.
Okay, we'll have to fix the UI so it
doesn't glitch like
that. But that's
How much faster?
Right. I thought we had like um really
fast training on a grid.
the grid
700, but I seem to
recall. Yeah, that's with a stupid mini
batch
size. Like if I just do
this. Okay, a grid hits two and a half
million with like actually a reasonable
size policy.
And then this is 4096
x2
M like this 32k should even be fine, I
guess. Is it the batch size that needs
to be
bigger? Like if I do this
It's really weird how like some of these
operations that should be similar flops
are just like 5x faster. Like neural MMO
can definitely go several times faster
than
this if we can just like get the PF out
of the GPUs.
doing. I'm pretty convinced it's
possible at this
point. Like literally, if I just did
this and I just do like policy
ready? Hop in Discord if you're
available for
that and don't mind being on stream.
Hey, good. Thank you. We just got Pong
to train 500 million steps in 35
seconds.
Okay,
it actually solves it, too.
That's pretty absurd. So, how much is
that per second? 15 million.
What What was the
really big batch sizes? So it's it turns
out I think that the two big bottlenecks
at the moment for standard networks is
you just need bigger batch sizes to
saturate and we need to figure out CUDA
overhead. Um I don't know. I I think
that the best thing is I'm just gonna
like get some fun little optimizations
and a cool a few cool demos for this
release and then I'm gonna like go act
like a monk for a month and just study
algorithms in the warehouse here and uh
figure out how to like get us some new
algorithmic games and then probably
after that it'll come back around to
like just optimize the hell out of Perf.
We'll see.
Is is it because most of the batch just
goes into the GPU for the algorithm
computations?
Um it's CUDA parallelism like they're
pretty small network so you actually
need very large batches to saturate the
GPU.
Okay, that's quite exciting. I can
actually tell just looking at some of
the results that I have though that like
as fast as Puffer Lib is, I think we can
make it several times faster.
That's pretty exciting. Like, and then
we haven't even touched uh distributed
data parallel yet because like I just
ordered the two tiny boxes. So, like
imagine we just train, we get this
several times faster and then we have
like neural MMO 3 train at 10 million
steps per second or something like that.
And we can train like a trillion time
step runs in a day or
two. That'd be something. That would be
so good for all the ablations. And I
think we could just like that's probably
bigger scale training steps wise than
like Dota at that point.
Like do you reckon how many steps per
second it was training or something?
Like they were using distributed uh
Yeah, but they were training they were
at they had like a thousand GPUs but
like it was
slow. So
h I don't know. Food for thought.
Anyways, how can I help you?
Um, yeah. Okay. So, two things I wanted
to talk about. The first thing is uh PR.
So, I've improved my AMP and I'm I'm
ready to PR, but uh I tried to merge
with the latest dev stuff. I think
you've seen the message go through on
Discord. Basically, it wasn't working
for me. Uh so, I had to go back on a
stable dev uh branch. Now, uh, my
question is, how can I still contribute
if I'm not on the latest, uh, dev
branch? If you're pring to like the dev
branch, it's kind of my fault if stuff
doesn't work. Um, let me see. Okay,
because the thing is that it worked on
yours, it worked on bet. Like, he tried
to help me on Discord, but on me, it's
just it's not I can tell where it's
blocking because I' i've tried to debug,
but I don't understand why. It's
basically blocking into the uh
multipprocessing class into the receive
function. Uh there is no ready workers
and all the fs are either just blocked
there or like super slow. I mean
training at like 1k steps per second.
Okay, let's see what we have
here. Which PR?
Oh, sorry. So, I ended up not doing it
because uh I wanted to ask you the
question like how basically how to do it
if I'm not on the latest uh on the
latest commit. Uh you would just PR it
to dev and then make it my job to copy
the files over once I fix all the crazy
things I'm doing with the release
branch. You kind of are doing this at a
little bit of a unique time. Like the
hardest the absolute hardest time to PR
stuff is in the few weeks leading up to
release because what tends to happen is
before every release I will just like
slice and dice the entire codebase. And
basically what that is is me going
through like all the accumulated bad
decisions that I've made over the last
six months and just like really trying
to simplify stuff so that the like the
release version of the code is really
simple and easy to follow. Um, so like
I've rewritten the whole trainer like
four times in the last week and got
Yeah. And also this one's particularly
bad because like we're shipping CUDA and
there's like extra jank from that. So,
okay. So, okay. Got you. Well, I'm not
in a hurry or anything. So, you know
what? I think it'll be best if I just
wait for the release and I'll be back.
Well, we want to get it into the
release.
You do? Okay. Well, then I'll just Yeah,
I'll just PR in the meantime now. It
will take me two seconds. Yeah, PR and
I'll take a quick look at it, right?
Okay. And let's see if I can help you
right now. And then if not, then uh you
know, we'll wait until I get it stable
in a day or two or more
stable and then we'll go from there.
Okay, so it should be
done. It says has configs and [ __ ]
Probably quite messy,
should definitely change this to like
just be like common resource or
something. Um because everyone's going
to think that this is like
the you know like just compression M or
whatever.
Oh, okay. Sorry. I think you actually
told me the same last time. I'll I'll
make it sure to to do it next one.
And this is Syon version.
Yeah, that's fine.
We got
grid.h looks like you have a few just
like or a hardcoded map.
Yeah, for cuz now uh I start my M resets
quite a bit more often. So I just wanted
to make sure that the reset was faster.
What's this?
why are there changes to sweep? Oh, yes.
Sweep weren't working with scale stuff.
So, but it's probably just on my on my
current uh you should generally the one
thing you should try to avoid doing is
modifying like any of my core stuff when
you're doing uh when you're pring things
cuz like this I don't know if you break
my sweeps doing this.
Yeah. Can you take this one file out of
the out of the PR?
Yep.
And if you just do that, then I can
merge it. Okay. Do Do I need to close
the PR to and open a new one without it,
or is it possible to just remove it? I'm
going to be honest, I have no idea.
Okay, so I'm going to be honest with you
here. I have no
idea. I don't have to I don't have to
deal with this stuff because it's my own
repo and I'm like always just merging my
own
code. Okay. Well, I'll do it this way. I
I'll close it and I'll open a new one.
This is totally true, but um two days
off is too much.
PR you have or you still figuring out?
I'm still figuring out because the I
actually changed it in the old commit.
So I think I just Is it Is it okay if I
um basically just copy paste the uh
current sweep uh file or is it going to
be too messy? Yeah, you can do
whatever. If you paste the current
sweep, the diff should go away.
Yeah, right.
Okay, so this is what I was expecting
here. Um, with the same LSTM but a flat
encoder policy, neural MMO 3 trains at
1.2 million steps per
second without any other changes.
So, I think that there's got to be
something
to I don't know if it's the comms or
what, but something needs to be
optimized there for
sure. How slow are comms supposed to
be? I guess it's kind of an expensive
operation, right?
Coms are more than just like it's more
flops than params by a
lot. But that doesn't even make sense
cuz we have comms on the maze and the
maze runs 2.5 million.
Maybe the size is just uh smaller,
right?
[Music]
I don't know. We'll have to see.
It definitely has fewer input channels.
Million step per second neural MMO would
be awesome.
Okay, the comms were eating a fair bit
of it, it looks like.
So I don't know why literally using the
exact same sweep
uh version that you have and it still
appears in uh in a PR um
still appears
Well, is it the same? Does it show a
diff?
Yeah, and it's definitely something I
haven't changed. There's actually one
only one thing that I changed long time
ago. I think it was the an if statement
on scale. Okay. I I can just merge that
then for you. No worries. Um uh yeah,
I'm sorry. It's quite messy, but
that's
okay. Me one second to finish this
thought.
It just changed. But that's stuff that
you've you've done definitely because I
haven't. Yeah. All the init stuff that's
not stuff I've done. Uh and I just
copied exactly the same files.
before. The only thing I'm not so sure
is that if you scroll down, you you have
a in in my PR, I think they show an if
statement at some point.
Trying to see if you'd put tabs or
something, but no.
Yeah, this line 59. That might be the
only thing that uh
I'm going to keep the release version
anyways. So, like it's fine. We'll just
merge this. Okay.
Okay, maybe I shouldn't push my in
files, right? Uh, no. You're So, you can
push this one. It's just misnamed cuz we
prefix everything with puffer. So, I
changed it from CPR to puffer
CPR. Fine. And then this is your stable
version. So we'll
keep we'll keep your config, I guess, if
it trains. Well, the thing is that
that's my config on the CPU, right? So
it's probably very different from what
you Well, yeah, but we still need like
we still don't have one that actually
trains well, right?
Yeah. Which would be a good thing to
have.
So that that one trains well in a sense
that it's uh it's really learning to to
eat everything, but I've added like a
lot of new features in the environment.
it's still not able to uh manage to uh
you know farm the resources and and stay
alive over a long
added there's so many of
these. This is just the log change is
fine.
So much
stuff.
There's it. Shouldn't it reset the log
here? Oh, so what I did is I added just
one log per instead of having uh
one log per agent.
So because it's like a a teamwork
basically uh I just made it easier.
It's weird that one didn't go through
cuz uh I fixed the It's just a It's just
a typo. Yeah, it's a typo in the H. I
fixed it.
Okay. So, this is where I wanted to do
um it's easier if things are
divisible. Our powers of two are
divisible at least by like 256 or
128 with the new kernels.
Okay. You can you can do it without like
if you really need to. It's just
going? I've been told box 7 has not been
good for a few
days. I think the plan is going to be to
I'll get it rebooted on Monday, but
we're slowly going to ship all the boxes
over.
Um, we also are getting two tiny boxes.
I don't know if those will help with
Pokemon because you're core bound unless
it's like unless you have a way to like
massively scale up the policy.
But I think we would have to wait until
we do more puffer algorithm style
stuff, a week or
two. Well, I mean, if there's a hardware
issue, is there a hardware issue with
the thing? Does it need to go to Main
Gear? I see it's been down since May
3rd, the one
week. Do you know
why? It like it matters if there's a
hardware issue versus anything else.
The boxes all just go behind me on the
uh the racks over here now.
Nice life.
Thank you. Yeah, that guy. Exactly.
Right. Not a boxing gym. There's no I
mean I've got You really should put a
ring out there.
I don't do any um martial arts type
training. I would enjoy it a lot to be
honest, but
like I don't know. I would only really
enjoy striking martial arts. I wouldn't
do like jiu-jitsu or anything. And like
concussion risk is just stupid.
Yes. So see what happen. So, okay, maybe
it's something to do with my code. I
don't know. But what's happening right
now, like not training, this is exactly
what happened to
me.
Um, okay. So, it is not my fault. Cool.
I will I'll have that rebooted on
Monday. We just have three pieces of
equipment here so far. There is more
arriving on Monday and then uh more a
arriving after that later in the
week and then tiny box is arriving in a
couple weeks. Okay, this thing just
doesn't run.
agents 512 *
8 4096
Okay. So, maybe I'm thinking I just
[ __ ] something up because this is
exactly what happens to me in the latest
dev branch.
So, can you try a quicky like breakout
uh pong or something just to make sure I
haven't [ __ ] everything
boxes. If you're just streaming
inference, that's
like massively overpowered for just
streaming inference, right?
training. Well, I'll let you use one of
them, but not if it's going to be like
if you're going to like have the
hardware sitting at like 10% GPU
utilization though, right? Like cuz
you're going to get CPU bound so damn
fast. It's 32 cores for six GPUs.
Yes, we bought two of
them. They will be arriving in like two
weeks. They have 64090s a piece. So, we
are doubling our we're doubling the
number of GPUs we have. Uh I bought
those because I have no idea when the
tariffs are going to come down on the
other boxes. Uh, so I figured I would
just like get something for now so that
we have
something. No, I can get the small CPU
only boxes. I can get um I I got to talk
to Lean Key cuz he sent a thing and then
I couldn't find the boxes to like to
where to buy them. Um, but yeah, we will
get like that server rack that's back
there. Yeah, over there. Uh, we will
have be able to put some like little CPU
machines into. I just need to know like
where to actually go click buy on a
thing of those and I'll get
some experiments with larger batch
sizes. Yes, but you're still you're hard
bound by CPU. So unless you figure out a
way that actually like can effectively
leverage 100 million parameter networks
or something, you're going to be sat
you're still going to be CPUbound.
So from my testing so far, I'm skeptical
of off
policy like in general.
Um, B trace does not work from my
tests. Like just something like like I
don't think any of the off policy
correction things actually
work. It would have to be like a
complete
restructuring.
Um, yeah, like you'd have to completely
restructure.
I actually have an algorithm dev blog
where I'm looking at this stuff after
the release where I'm going to spend
like a month on this stuff, but I think
I'm going to be looking at more than
just off policy
there. That is going to be one
component. Okay, so this
runs and for some reason this
doesn't I just double check it actually
runs on mine.
So that's weird.
Also that guy like off policy does not
let you just infinitely scale hardware
either. You're still very strongly
constrained by
data generating data while training
epoch is
going. The problem is you're not going
to just be like off by a factor of two.
Like yes, technically if training takes
about as long as inference for instance,
like you can still be doing roll outs
while you're doing but like you're going
to be off by a massive factor with
Pokemon cuz you're only going to be able
to
generate
like let's say 20 30,000 steps a second
on 32 cores, right?
set. Like the only thing I know that can
saturate that at this point would be
like neural
MMO because 32 cores M runs at like a
million million and a half steps a
second a core. I can saturate that all
day. I can make neural MMO brain
depending how well I optimize anywhere
from like 3 to 10 million steps per
second.
32 cores, 64090s per box, and we've got
two of
them. So, they're mostly very good
for sixes weight. Yeah, exactly right.
That's what I mean. So, you have to
either have fast M, scalable network, or
GPU like accelerated M. Like, you need
one of those things.
which is why I would have preferred to
have bought like I would have preferred
to buy one of those boxes and like six
extra
desktops, but the desktops were over
seven grand last I got
quoted and I think they've probably gone
up. I don't really see a reason to do
that, right?
I don't really see a reason to do like
LLM play
Pokemon. It's kind of just a dumb trendy
thing to do right
now. Hey, we got some uh we got some
eyes on the Pokemon project though from
that. I think you saw this. That was
funny as hell.
from the Google guys, right? They said,
"Oh man, we got we got we pissed off a
few of them. It was funny."
Where' they go?
Yeah, this was
funny. Who would
win? All of Google or one
puffer? Eat Google.
Yeah, this thing is just not running.
So, what's up with that?
So, when I was pulling the latest step,
I saw it was basically stuck into the
vector uh five. Okay. So, if I do serial
Okay. So, something must be happening
because it's running there on mine. So,
something must be happening
with
H. So, this is one of the really well I
guess it doesn't help that much with Seg
faults specifically
um because we still haven't figured out
compile settings for this. though we do
actually we actually can set break
points in Python with the new bindings
and have them like drop into the
C which is pretty useful.
How is it possible that the amp runs in
C when I'm just testing it without, you
know, row without any policy or anything
and it's like faulting this way?
Well, you're using it differently,
right? Like the C just demo just makes
one end. There a whole bunch of extra
places with what the Python does that
you can seg stuff. Can't you run with
GDB and get a back brace? Not really
with Syon.
bindings? Okay. Well, actually it means
that the latest death branch uh stuff's
doing
something that makes the amp crash. So,
I guess that's uh at least I got a good
direction to look into. I can
technically do this. I don't think it'll
do anything though.
I've kind of looked at their debugging
before and I've kind of just kind of
just been
go. Oh.
Huh. Somehow this is actually giving me
um giving me something here. Cool. I
guess I was wrong.
somehow? Yeah, it's probably gets
allocated in like
Yeah, fluts gets allocated in the
creation of the
Unintentional free is really rare with
these puff rims. It's way more common.
We just don't free anything.
things. Sure thing plasma we are just
hanging out in the discord so you can
jump in There.
Net
CCPR. Let's get called.
Yeah, this should Yeah, that's the one
that should be getting called.
I was looking to see if you didn't set
this or
this. Looks like you do, though.
weird. And this part is exactly the
same.
How much is the vision in your in file?
Should be
three.
Yep. I changed numb agents to eight.
end. Oh, okay. It's not Okay, it's not
training anymore when I change it to
eight.
Oh
dear. I'm sorry. Should have cut
that. Is there an eight hardcoded
somewhere
Yeah, I don't see 12 hardcoded anywhere.
And this worked before, so I didn't
suspect
anything. Like when I used to I'd train
it with eight, it was fine before.
Yeah. I mean, I can make it work with
12. You just end up with like
annoying annoying batching. Like mildly
annoying batching and it like
something's definitely wrong on my end
for sure. So I I'd better fix that. Um,
well, you can take a look at that and
then uh I will come back and we
can I don't know what that is. It's
weird that that thing isn't allocated.
Yeah. Okay. Well, yeah, I'll I'll fix
that on my end. Um, just another quick
stuff I wanted to bring up. Um I've uh
done some research to exploration stuff
and I've tried use puff a lip like how
do you so I've tried to implement some
papers on exploration I know try some
some stuff as well like how would that
work for me to contribute on that end so
for instance let's say I I implement a
paper and I don't know results are
either bad or good uh maybe we can
exchange that or yeah so we do have we
do actively want to be doing research on
this stuff. The problem is most
published methods are just
wrong. Um, or they're slow or they're
like some gotchas or they only work in
like a small fraction of Ms. I couldn't
get E3B to work at all and it's slow.
Um, I don't think really any like the
random network methods make much sense
at
all. And they're also like they
They also cost
extra. Um, Diane, some of the Diane
stuff that's in the dev branch, uh, is
actually quite promising. I'm taking it
out for release, but that's not cuz
we're killing it. It's just because it's
not currently doing anything. So, we
only want the good for like the good
stuff in the current version. So, there
is room for an exploration algorithm of
some type. But the bar for
like thing just becomes puffer default
is probably like yeah this is just
generally good across all or almost all
the M's and if there's any sort of speed
to penalty it's worth
it so it's tough.
Okay. What do you think if So I try to
do my stuff on my own. If I find
anything that's great I'll just ping you
obviously. Yeah. Um well what you would
do is you would just you would just have
your version your fork of puffer lib
right and you just implement stuff in
there. It's meant to be like puffer is
very it's like a very flat code
structure. So it's like it's supposed to
be really easy to just hack new methods
into it without having to like think too
much about a bunch of moving parts. Um
and then really what you want to do is
you just want to see does this thing
actually consistently make a difference
across all m. I think generally with
puffer when you hit on something good
that like hits the bar the cool thing is
it's very obvious like with Muon it was
super obvious right it was like night
and day with just ease of tuning and
hyperp sensitivity and all of that so
it's like we're kind of looking for
stuff like that
okay uh what do you think about like
would you want to keep a list of things
that didn't work so you know if I tried
something or maybe you tried something I
can tell you what I tried that I
couldn't didn't get to work right. I
tried E3B.
I think I messed a little bit with R&D,
but I didn't really try that hard. Um, I
messed with Diane quite a bit and it
seemed promising in some ways, but I
couldn't get like a general performance
boost out of it. Diane type stuff is
pretty promising.
Um yeah, generally like it's tough
because exploration is an area where
like a lot of the research really isn't
defining the problem correctly and like
they just or like they test on not great
MS. Uh the M that we have that's really
good for testing stuff is the maze
environment. Yeah, that's exactly the
one I've been testing. Yeah, it's really
good for that. And um we if you've seen
some of the policies we've trained
lately, we have the best maze solving
agents by a mile, at least as far as
I've ever seen in RL. Um and it was just
like our advantage filtering stuff is
really good because you kind of just
throw out all the bad training segments.
Uh and you have like this prioritized
replay thing and it's like really really
really
effective. So like ironically that's
been the best thing so far.
Well, I think aspiration has to do
either one or two things. One, it either
just finds a better policy uh in the
limit or it just uh enables you to to
obtain the maximum score faster. It's
like one of the two, right? You have to
have some sort of definition of what
exploration is supposed to be. Like in
my
mind it should be like seek out
uncertain regions when you're not making
progress or something like that, right?
So it's like if you don't know what to
do, go try
stuff. You would hope that it would be
something like that. Like the thing is
it's it's quite hard to define not
knowing what to do. Like imagine you
have a very simple amp where you know
the fir the first step you get a nice
reward but then there's like a hidden
reward like thousand step further and
your agent might never seen it because
just he's like okay well it's when your
average reward plateaus
right you should be able to see that
your value loss is very low your ve you
have very low surprisal right your
policy loss is very low the policy is
very stable it's kind of just like you
don't know what to do anymore to do any
better. That's when you should start
trying stuff. But then trying stuff
doesn't just mean taking random actions
either, right? Yeah. Yeah. So I I have a
specific idea about that. Like I think
it's it has to do with like if you're
talking about like world model like the
way you would explore is that you have a
a distribution in mind into how things
should evolve like into the next step
next state transition probabilities like
you have an expectation of this and when
something doesn't match that expectation
uh this is when you're probably wrong
about it but then it means like this
definition is very intuitive. But then
it means that you need a world model
which is I mean you know it is what it
is. Well I mean there's stuff like this
with like I mean as old as like the
intrinsic curiosity module or whatever
ICM there are like a lot of methods that
are kind of
adjacent. Um and just none of them have
worked all that well.
I was wondering if it wasn't because of
the word model stuff that I mean if your
world model is kind of shitty you might
have the best uh exploration module or
curiosity based module it's not going to
work right and I think word model like
basically model based error has been
quite shitty
um from what I can say it's tough
because like people are saying dreamer
is working on a lot of stuff now but
like if it is working, it's not working
for any of the reasons listed in the
paper because we we have a ner paper on
that. It was [ __ ]
Um so yeah, I don't I don't really know
because actually the one I've been exper
there are two papers I've been
experimenting experimenting sorry with.
uh the one is the ICM module and the
second one is some sort of curiosity
based uh module added to the PO
um
algorithm
and I think there there might be
something something there but so far
what I can say is just it adds it
basically adds another network on top of
it so so it just slows everything down
too much to be worthy
Okay. Well, uh, yeah, I'll keep looking
into that direction. I'll fix that stuff
into the Mayan and I I'll come back to
you. Sounds good. Okay. Thank you very
much.
Where's plasma?
You here?
I'll be back in a
minute. A couple quick steps
in and grab a drink and then either he
will be back or we will do more
optimization on stuff.
right. Okay. Plasma's not here. So, we
will keep doing a little bit of perf him
on uh Neural MMO until he shows up.
result. We're still not close to
matching though,
right? Like if I do
Oh, hang
on. This is actually really close,
1632. Oh, hang on. We need to change
some things. Make the comparisons fair.
Oh, wait. This doesn't have an RNN. This
is just Okay, so this is closer to
comparable. So,
it's 9% M 26
forward. The 2.2 2 mil
parameter. Okay, forward is
like close
here. There is this extra copy
overhead
15%. 16 forward 32 learn.
close. Still a little off,
but say pretty close.
And then what is it? It's
4096 by
two. I mean, this is virtually the same
at this point.
So then from
1.8 we go to here and we lose like half
of
it. Yeah, we lose half of our speed with
a few com
layers. I guess there's this big one
hot as well.
optimizations. At least I know now
what's
happening. I'm kind of happy with that
for now. Like to at least know what's
happening.
Maybe that's a decent compromise. 128
still gets you 700k.
well. And then we
do we set compile true
now. Okay. So somehow we're running out
of
Compute capability not
supported. Seem
Bizarre. Compute capability not
supported would
be very weird.
Do we get anything out of Bloat? Even
though it's like nerfed or
good. I'm actually interested to see how
this runs.
Let me uh let me see if I run this real
quick.
I just want to get a neural MMO run
going.
I'm trying to think how
um how we should
do sweeps and stuff in
general like with the the batch sizes of
everything.
mil. That's 3.4
mil. Yeah. So there's like major
differences here on between the two
cards.
Hey, plasma.
So I think it's pretty
weird like the
um I guess I just ceue it up on
uh upper max maybe.
They're like major major performance
differences
uh between
chips in like a way that seems like it's
like batch size or caching or some
I'm actually Hang on. Let me go find
what the original params were. No, you
know what? Let's just help you
first. Just help you first. Jump in the
Discord.
Hey, how's it going?
Good, good. Um um I think I'm almost
done with uh the voids. Like I got um I
got the the I can like the actions work.
Um the um observations are uh coming up
I think. Um now I'm basically just I
guess trying to train it and see how it
goes. I need to still adjust like the
rewards and stuff like that.
Um but basically
um when I try to train it
um like I basically updated yesterday to
the newest dev branch and I rebased it.
Um, and when I try to train it,
uh, uh, I get to the, um, like you have
some slices stuff. Mhm. H, wait.
Incorrectly set up
environment. Uh, yeah. But basically,
um, I have like, um, I I run into this
problem in clean puffer RL. You get
stuck on slices not hashable.
Yeah, exactly. Okay, so that's fixed in
release that's fixed in release branch.
That is a Python 311 issue. It works in
312 on that as well. So the Python devs
decided that slices shouldn't be
hashable and then they changed their
mind. So Ah, okay. I'm on 311. So I
should switch to 312. Mhm. Either switch
to 312 or it's fixed in the release
branch.
Yeah, I can just switch to 312. It's
not. Um, what's the release? So what's
the difference between the dev and the
release like is the release branch? So
main like the 20 is the stable one,
right? The dev one is where I do all my
crazy things. Mhm. And then the release
branch is now where I'm doing all the
really crazy things where it's like,
okay, if uh you want it to be even more
janky than dev, but you want to be up to
date with all this like the hacks I'm
doing to really get this thing ready for
release, like there's absolutely no
promises that stuff won't change
constantly there for the next couple
weeks because the thing is like I'm
really just slicing and dicing
everything to get the code into a good
state for release. Um, we are now at
like a,000 lines or I think without the
space it's like 900 lines for the whole
demo plus clean puff RL in
release. Um, nice. So, I'm just like
trying to make everything super compact
and simple and easy to follow. Yeah. Oh,
yeah. Yeah. And and do you do you guys
have any like uh testing things you guys
are doing or the only thing that we
actually have um test for? It's not even
really applicable. Like there's some
stuff in emulation that's kind of janky
that we have test for but uh we really
don't do a ton of like CI type automated
testing.
It's mostly like the test is can you
train the M's because right there aren't
any better tests you can write than do
the M's train or like end to end that's
yeah cuz like in RL I don't know how you
would like write tests you can't really
I mean you could totally write like
standard tests on all the software
components but it's just it's really not
my style because like I I don't like to
have like these like nice clean modules
where everything is separated and does
its own thing and is tested. Like I
slice and dice stuff constantly and like
my biggest priority is keeping
everything as simple as it const as it
could possibly be. So like if I can
redefine like what is like what is
interacting with what and in a way that
will make stuff simpler, I will always
do that. Um like it's basically the
tests are just more work. They would be
more work to maintain than they would be
worth with the way that I do stuff.
Yeah, because from what I'm hearing, you
basically want your code to be as uh
easy like as malleable as possible like
as easily malleable as possible and
tests. Yeah. Kind of like set the code
concretely like they kind of you know
the way the code is I the way I call is
like I say that I write white box
software. So like the goal is not that
you have clean API boundaries and you
just read the docs. The goal is that you
have like this possible easiest to
follow thing that is just infinitely
hackable um and also very quick to like
prototype new stuff on
and those are two very different kind of
like um it sounds very much like uh uh
Ray Lib's approach. Yeah. And Ray is my
favorite probably one of my favorite if
not my favorite library. So
yeah, makes sense. Uh yeah, so I'm
basically just having I guess training
issues. So I now I switch to 312. Let's
see if that fixes it. Python setup.py
build
extensions. I'm going to recompile the
ends.
So, uh, just to get back on like the
branches thing, what would you recommend
I develop voids on? Like what should be
my base? What branch you on now? Dev.
Just finish it there and then like
probably by some point next week, we'll
have release get merged back into dev
with like but stable this time. Um, and
then we can like do all the changes we
need because I want to have this end in
the release. I want to have um C uh CPR
in the release. I basically want all the
new M stable and training in the release
possible.
Yeah. All right. Cool. So, I'm just
going to stay on dev and rebase when uh
um when uh you call the release merges.
Sounds good. Okay. Uh let me see if
demo.py P
DN D mode
train. Let's see if it
trains.
Okay. UDA unknown error. This might be
to incorrectly set up
environment. Who is
is this?
Uh yeah, I can share screens.
probably be easier for you to actually
see what what's happening on my screen.
So, right now I'm getting a CUDA
error.
Um, and this
is spec goes all the way back to a
classifier policy make policy
uh and then policy arc. This I think
right now what's happening is something
like CUDA is not working well.
changing. Does Nvidia smi run? Yeah,
let's do
Nvidia.
SMI run, you said. So, like this. No,
no, you're good. I was just Yeah. Um,
let me think. Uh, let me check. This is
dev branch. Yeah. Yeah. I don't think I
don't think any of the really jank stuff
that should cause that is in the dev
branch is the thing.
I don't know. I'm just Let's see. I'm
just shooting my shot. No, no, no, no.
Yeah, that doesn't work. Um, like I
don't think that I did. Like there is
stuff that would cause that, but it
shouldn't be in the dev branch.
Yeah. No, it's not there, man.
Okay. Interesting.
You have CUDA dev.
CUDA dev. What is that? CUDA. Like, are
you in a container or where are you? Uh,
no. I'm just on Linux. on just my uh you
installed CUDA
right at some point. Yes, I have I have
CUDA. I should have the what was it like
the C um the CUDA compiler and what was
it called? CUDA
compiler.
Uh what's the name of
it name?
NVCC. NVCC. Yeah. Well, there's like the
only thing I'm not sure this did this
work before? Uh yeah, this I this is
actually a new error. Before I got that
slice air, now I'm getting this error.
The thing is I don't
know. Oh, you're on 118. Okay. You're on
an old Yeah, cuz I'm on a 1080. Oh,
okay. But yeah, the one thing I'm not
sure then is cuz like the new So some of
the new stuff in Puffer, we have CUDA,
we have CUDA uh we have a CUDA kernel
that ships, right? And um I'm fixing
this so that there will be a CPU
fallback. But at the moment if you want
to compile that kernel, you need not
just the CUDA runtime, you actually need
CUDA dev.
All right. So I like the thing is I
don't actually know what you have
installed because I know how when I set
it up on a container, it's just the
difference of having your base Docker
image be their CUDA runtime or their
CUDA like dev version. You can see it in
like the latest Docker. But I think that
that's probably the uh the issue for
you. Okay. No, no. Oh, well, still even
on CPU. Wow. So, well, I it's probably
just trying it's probably just trying to
compile the kernel anyways, honestly.
Uh yeah, there isn't a fallback. Like, I
haven't added the fallback in yet. So,
like again, this is just like this is
stuff because we're like a few weeks
from release, right? And I've done all
these new things, but like I haven't
added the fallbacks yet. So what should
happen is if you don't have CUDA dev um
what should happen is it should compile
the CPU version of it and then that one
operation will just run the CPU version
but there's no fallback now so it just
errors I mean technically I do have uh
NVCC I guess how would you what would
you what do you mean by CUDA dev do you
mean CUDA dev tools I should have it um
let's see I should have CUDA dev tools
actually um I mean I What's it I mean
what is it called? It's like CUDA
developer
CUDA compiler version I guess if you
have
NVC. I do have it right here.
Okay. So like hang on then. Let's scroll
up. Let's see. Let's see. So train
right. Oh, it gets to Eval. That's
weird.
Yeah. Why is it eval? Yeah, it gets to
EV then. So that's weird then that it
gets there. Yeah. And you do with the
trace back like there's a there's a flag
that it gives you
CUDA unknown error.
Wait, this may be
change in after program start setting
variable.
If you like import torch is CUDA
available? Yeah, let's see. Uh I can
just import torch. torch
um what's it called? Is it's torch.cuda
is available is underscore available.
Okay. CUDA dot um is underscore
available like this
false okay then something is wrong with
my torch. Mhm. Okay. You might just have
to re if you just if you just
reinstalled stuff you might have to
reboot it or something. I don't know.
Ah, because I just Yeah, I just UV pip
installed. Um, I can try. Oh, it's
because I'm on Give me a second. Let me
see if I start a new shell. Yeah, this
was the
activate. Let me make sure I'm on the
right thing. Okay, it's my Python. Good.
Let's try this. Import
torch.
Torch.CUDA is available.
Uh, no. Okay.
Uh, I mean, I do have Nvidia. I guess
this is just a PyTorch issue. Um, and I
do have
NVCC, but
okay. Well, okay. At least it's not a
puffer lib issue and I got rid of that
uh slice error. So, yep. So, that should
be decent for you. And then uh you know
in a few days we'll have this. And I
think it'll be pretty cool to have these
uh to have this M doing like stuff to
have just puffers going everywhere.
It'll be fun. You know what I feel like
will be cool is to have this env on the
website and then allow people to kind of
interactively add obstacles and stuff.
Yeah. Interact with the puffers. There's
stuff you could do like that for sure.
Yeah, that would be fun. Um, but yeah, I
I think yeah, I'll continue debugging
the thing, the torch thing that's not a
a for lib issue. So, at some point, I'm
going to allow myself to go have some
fun and build some M's instead of just
like relentlessly optimizing the hell
out of stuff and like banging my head
against research. But for now, we have
reinforcement learning to fix and things
must be fast.
That pong thing right there actually
gives me a ton of hope that like Yeah,
we can probably make a lot of the stuff
in Pupper just run substantially faster.
Yeah, I mean we can like um I think
though what's important is not just
going straight away and trying to uh
vectorize for example like the ends or
something like that. I would first just
look at where are the odd paths like hot
co paths and optimize those most of the
effort of those it's all like the uh we
get torchbound now is the thing so it's
like it's torch device transfer and
torch but the thing is I don't know if
like there's weird stuff where like
differences to batch size matter more
than they should and like certain
networks that should be similar in flop
count are like way slower than other
networks. So, um I think that there's
just like something with the kernels
being generated and yeah, with torch
compile. Well, because torch compile
doesn't freaking work like it just
doesn't do stuff. Um I would look into
So, do you know lightning uh PyTorch
Lightning? Yep.
um the the like the kind of company that
spun out of it
um has their own like pietorch compiler.
Oh jeez. It's Yeah. Do I want to look at
that? Like lightning is like the classic
bad PyTorch library. Like is it? I don't
know. It's like the it's like the rapper
of PyTorch because PieTorch was too
lowle for companies that don't know how
to code. like literally
or caris caris before that right caris
is the one for tensorflow so it's the
kis for it's like the caris for torch
it's just like bad dumb software for
people who can't code but but that's the
thing like keras was a good starting
point at least for me that's how I
started uh doing machine learning is I
started with keras because I did not
know how to you know do all the math
stuff oh man lucky you I started
freaking trying to like implement com
backward pass in mat lab no I wish it
was tensor flow one was that and then it
was cafe one if you ever used cafe one
and then it was TensorFlow one. Yeah,
cafe one where you have to like you
suffer forever to get it to work and
then you write god awful schema files.
All right. And then after that it was
TensorFlow one which made absolutely no
bloody sense. Okay. And then it was like
PyTorch super beta version which was
where I got my first paper. And then
after that then we finally got things
that sometimes work but actually still
today none of the deep learning
frameworks really work at all.
I I guess yeah I mean I did yeah I guess
I got lucky in the sense of like I did
have to implement my own thing from
scratch in the beginning but I did you
know eventually I think most people who
are into machine learning implemented
their own like um tensor library. Yeah
we have one in puffer for inference. We
have puffernet.h
Yeah. Um, well, I'm going to give
you, you don't have to look at it, but
if you feel like, you know, looking at
if they have a better compiler,
apparently their compiler skips the PTX
steps, like sometimes, so what they do a
lot of times is they um, well, they're
saying they're faster than PyTorch by
40%. That's, you know, I mean, that's
got to be like the thing is it's
completely dependent on
speed up versus Well, it's
not Wait, they're comparing to eager
mode.
Mhm.
Oh, so these guys just lie. Is that what
this is? Is that that what they do?
Yeah, they just lie because what they
did is they wrote a graph where they
compared their compile mode to PyTorch
eager
mode. And PyTorch eager mode is not the
compile. PyTorch compile. So they
compared their compile to not compile.
Wait, no way. That's what they have.
Yeah, maybe this is not the thing you
want to look at then.
Yeah, I just saw this cuz I talked to I
was like at a lightning meet up. No, one
of the lightning guys showed me this.
Well, I mean, it's really easy to sell
your stuff if you just freaking do that.
Yeah. I mean, yeah. 40% faster than
PyTorch. Let's go. Yeah. This is
honestly one of the things I run into
with Puffer where it's like, okay, you
can't have it be a thousandx faster,
right? Like if you if you say your
software is a thousandx faster or you're
just you're just lying. Yeah. Yeah. But
it's actually a thousand times faster
because you actually it's actually Yeah.
It's actually a thousandx faster. Like
the one time it actually is. It's like
look Yes. technically the baseline like
people were writing their MS in
unoptimized Python but that's not my
fault.
Yeah. Yeah. And in unoptimized like a
lot of for loops by god awful python.
Yeah. Like crafter numpy. Oh man. It's
like there's so much stuff that's just
like wrong in emo. Like crafter was
written as like oh yeah it's supposed to
be like a a more faster than Atari. Like
it's supposed to be like a a fast
benchmark for whatever. It's literally
slower than Atari. Like 20x OpenAI's
Atari. Uh, no. Open. No, no. This is uh
Danager's like crafter and the original
Python one. It runs like a few hundred
steps per second. It's awful.
Oh, is it all just Python? Just It's the
worst optimized Python you've ever seen.
Yes. Oh my god. It's like doing
software. It's software rendering in
Python loops. It's awful.
Oh my god. Yeah. Um yeah, you know, I
think after once I get um voids going
and it's working well, I'm really
interested in helping optimize stuff.
That would be very nice because I'm so
sick of it. Like I would love uh helping
with that. Yeah, I wanted So I guess the
plans for me going forward, obviously
there's business stuff that I have to do
to like you know, servers ain't cheap. I
just bought two tiny boxes. That's 50
grand. Yes. Um, yes. I'm surprised you
bought them.
We needed GPUs.
We needed GPUs, so I got us GPUs. But
yeah, I want to get a lot more than
that, right? I want to get like another
30 plus boxes for behind me. Um, not
tiny boxes, mind you, but like single
node stuff um when the tariffs come
down. So, you know, we not I got to make
sure that the company is doing well. But
aside from that, the plans going
forward, I'm going to spend after this
release, I'm probably going to spend
like a month just trying to go through
all of the deep mind papers and just
everything algorithmically. I want to
understand like everything that is out
there that actually matters
algorithmically in RL. Um, and I want to
see like what if it actually matters for
Puffer so that we kind of like not only
is Puffer the fastest, we also just we
have the best implementation, the
whatever like across the board, right?
And then from there, I think like we
kind of have RL in a really good spot
because we have all of this like super
optimized tooling and then if we can
just like get whatever missing pieces of
algorithms. I don't know if it means
going to off policy. I don't know if it
means having like scalable search where
like you can have like MCTS rollouts uh
if you want to. Um I don't know what it
means yet, but that's kind of the plan.
And then like from there it's pretty
much if we have that then it's like we
should just be able to solve everyone's
problems in industry and ideally make
enough along the way to just fund all
sorts of awesome research along this.
That's kind of where my head's at.
Yeah. And I'm I'm guessing you're also
like very in touch with the RL community
and how they kind of view the library
and how what they think of it. I mean a
lot of the the RL community is really
isolated to be honest. Like I don't plug
as much into the existing academic
community at the moment because it's
like it's very entrenched and like
there's a reason that RL has been
stalled since 2019 and it largely has to
do with the way that the academic
community does research. I spent five
years trying to change people's minds
with the way I was developing neural
MMO. It really like people are really
really stubborn. But like I kind of am
just ignoring that entirely now with
Puffer. And it's just look, I'm building
these tools. At some point it's like
you're crazy not to use them with how
much faster and how much better stuff
is. And if you still don't want to,
that's on you, right? I'm like I'm not
I'm no longer trying to change people's
minds. It's more just like I'm building
good stuff. We can solve your problems.
Like we're getting people coming to us
saying, "Hey, can you help us solve our
problems now with all the stuff you've
built?" And that's like that's more my
focus. I don't want to spend my time
trying to convince people of things. I
want to really just spend my time
building this stuff more than anything.
Yeah. And and and well, it'll be cool
though like for people who do use your
library like getting feedback and like I
mean they can do that through issues,
right? Through GitHub issues. I mean
it's a lot easier to get a hold of me
than issues, right? I'm like I stream
all the devs. I'm all over X and the
Discord and every so it's like I try to
make it very very much like that when I
can. Yeah. Yeah. All right. Cool. Um,
yeah, I'm looking forward. I want to
finish the boys. We'll we'll get uh was
uh running well. Um, and yeah, I'm gonna
probably go now, enjoy a bit of this sun
that I have. Oh, yeah. Saturday. And uh
yeah. Yeah, I will be working on this
for the rest of today. I get to do I get
to go for a good long run in the morning
tomorrow. That is my son.
Cool. All right. I'm um I'm probably
going to be on later today, so I guess
I'll see you then. Cool. See you around.
Couple quick
things.
fly. Do a couple quick sets. I'm going
to go launch some experiments and then
we will uh go from there.
And having that equipment behind me is
very
convenient. I get like so much more
exercise in throughout the day. Even if
like compared to having it in a separate
garage, I just get so much more exercise
done. Been great for uh my productivity.
on I have no idea what you're doing,
Jason.
onboard graphics are not going to do
much of anything.
Okay, so I remember here this
was I was attempting to figure
out
why puffer neural MMO is so much slower
on the
Oh, okay. Like this is fine, right? This
is plenty fast. And
Uh-uh. Okay. This is genuinely just a
card difference.
diff. Um the 30 or the 5090 is not this
much faster.
So, I don't know why it's like this, but
we can at least run an experiment with
I don't even really want to run this to
be
Yeah, that's about it. Okay. So, it is
just GPU diff. It's kind of
weird. For some reason, it's just
dramatically faster this specific uh
network
is. So, that's
fine. Let me think how I want to
integrate this
with these new findings.
length. I think you need to know two of
three, right? You need to know for how
long you're going to roll
out, how many agents you're going to
have.
um or your batch
size. So, why don't I go back to local
here? I add some like auto
settings where like you can sweep over
the horizon.
instead of the batch size and it'll auto
set batch size for
you. And then we'll just make sure mini
batch size always is something like
sensible. We could do it that way.
and we'll see if um if that gets us
anything anything
better. We should be able to go like
substantially faster with
this,
Do you think reinforcement learning
algorithms can influence computer
vision? Uh, it
depends. It kind of depends on the
context. Like I'm sure people are
already running
um like RL on VLMs and
stuff. I mean RL has been used in
various contexts with like individual CV
algorithms.
But like yes, it's just uncertain like
in which capacities outside of like BLM
stuff. Yeah, I think what we're going to
do here, we get out of this box.
industry people are actively using using
active learning for
CV.
Yeah, actually what the heck are people
even calling that?
Oh, this is kind of like self- selected
curricula. Yeah, sure.
So we do something like this, right?
And
auto, we set
like we set this to be like 64. I
guess I guess we could set this to be
any number of things,
right? What was the issue I even had
sweeping
this? Oh, it's that they had to match
up, right?
So you actually you should be able to
sweep two of
these. So I think we do batch size auto
makes more
sense. And then this is like six. This
goes to be like
60 64.
And like what we'll probably end up
doing
here, we'll probably end up like setting
just some reasonable ranges for like
those. And then if we hit the top end or
the bottom end of the range at any
point, we'll like we'll revisit
Good
palm. If we do like batch size is auto
works. Man, it's going to take forever
to even get any stats.
want to go up to like 8x what we were
doing before.
Maybe this is like
14.8. If I go to like four
here, that's like 64,000 freaking
environments,
though. It's a
much. But I mean, 32k forward pass size
for very small nets.
good. If I limit to
this, I say we're not going to go
totally
crazy. We can still hit 15 on
this. All
right. I kind of like
that because then if I I make like the
unit like
um let's say I make it like a
4096 or even a
20 4096
maybe. And then I go like eight, eight
and four.
All I have to do is like min BPT
horizon, right? We do like BPT horizon.
Let's say
Oh, numb M's
actually. So, the smallest would be
131. I could just do
this. If I can just make like auto
This is probably kind of jank, but I
want to see if this does
anything. So, the idea is here is like
this is going to make it so we can sweep
stuff. like I should just be able to do
like num ms is
eight and it'll still run it on all the
cores. So now what we should actually be
able to
do, we can just
sweep number of cores. I guess up to
eight cores Maybe.
Let's see if based on this, let's see if
I can come up with like a new config
sweep.
You should leave
uh update epox
on the batch
size batch size actually doesn't get
swept anymore. It just goes to
auto. Uh BPT Horizon does does get swept
or does not get
The min is going to be
28. The
mean
This is going to mess up the CUDA kernel
though, isn't
like I could say
128x32. No, but if the BPT horizon is
bigger
mean, so there's got to be either a
compromise or something
here, provided I want to keep doing it
this way where like I disallow invalid
combinations from even existing.
Why don't we
compromise? Like you can go lower on BPD
horizon just not higher,
right? I'm pretty sure you can go
lower. So why don't I do like this? We
do 16 to
64. We'll set mean at 64. And if it
stays
here, we'll consider doing some other
stuff. We'll we'll do this one to 81
92. We'll set the mean at 32K.
right? And then sweep.train.tal
timesteps. I think it's better to leave
this out of the base
config. Oh, no. I need it in there
because of the way that carbs works,
don't I?
So this should be able to go from 20 mil
to
like I don't know 500 mil I
Right. We do M or vec numbum. Hang on.
It's numbum. M's like this.
Okay, so here's puffer breakout
training ludicrously fast.
You probably want
the defaults to be like actually good
though.
So here it's
training substantially
slower but it should actually optimize
this way.
interesting. I just ran this without
sweeps.
Help.
Cool. So we will
see provided this actually
evals. Looks like it does. We'll see if
that uh does not crash or not.
Cool. So, uh that plus fixes to that
should be I think all that would be
required for uh speedrun stuff. So like
what is the fastest possible time that
or fastest possible solve time for a
fixed environment because that should
let us like that should basically let us
sweep into some ridiculous
regimes. Might be a few other small
things we'd want to fiddle with in the
process of doing that. But um I don't
know. I think that that should give us
something
good. So, if I look back at the to-do
list from
this. Got this pretty darn well cleaned
up. Haven't done like a few of the small
things here.
This we are fine
with. NVPI
warnings. Easy
stuff. High quality sweeps. We're
working on
ablation. Okay. So, like we're pretty
well set up to
where I have the code mostly where I
want it. There are a lot of like small
little things to clean up. Then there's
packaging work, but like the sweeps are
getting to be in a spot
where I'm actually happy with what we
have.
Um, and we are going to be able to start
like tuning the individual environments
quite nicely. I'd say based on
this there are few gotchas still but
like this is a lot
better. So I think then what I should do
today now that like while I wait for
this to run and I'll check back in on
this every so often to make sure I fix
any little
crashes. Uh I just do all like the small
stuff
today that I've been putting off.
And then that'll put us in a better spot
for doing the final experiments for
everything as
well. And then we'll have like all of
next week pretty much to do that. And
then it's blogs and release and
packaging and all of
that. That sounds good to
me. I'm going to just like walk around
for a minute or two before we start on
that. Um, provided that this
is still
going. And this is still going and this
is actually like producing reasonable
results. So, cool. All right. I'm going
to just go like walk around for a
minute.
Um, refocus and then I'm going to come
back. We're going to do all like the
small stuff and hopefully we'll get the
release code into a spot where like I'm
happier giving it to people to like use
this for now.
Be
Here is the
uh here's the
plan.
233 got like one small planned
interruption. Got three and a half
hours right now.
I want to get all the small stuff
done so
that afterwards. Whoops.
afterwards, like a Monday and whenever,
we will for the most part
um be on to doing like final experiments
and anything with that.
There might be a few extra things with
like AM and terminals and whatever, but
like ablations, but for the most part,
we're going to be
doing
experiments next week. We're going to be
doing the
packaging docs, the
blog, and we're going to try to not let
this release drag on. I It's definitely
It's got to be this month. Um, ideally
within two
But yeah, we definitely we want to ship
this. Um, and depending on how good the
sweeps are will determine whether this
is a 2.5 or a 3.0 know since apparently
that's how we do versioning nowadays.
Dang it. Okay, we still have one thing
to
fix. Yeah, I forgot about that. That's
an easy one, though.
Okay, we'll see if that fixes it. I
think that should be enough to fix that
for now.
Put this over here so we don't get
confused.
So this is just
reformulating the uh the
previous name space as a dictionary.
I really liked that name space, but I
think it is better for
uh for the library not to have it.
Look at that. It literally changes the
value on
Yeah, this is a slightly annoyingly
large refactor for this,
but and like technically if I wanted to,
I could have kept this thing for
internal use
only, but I think it's better to like
Not. Okay. So, there's breakout running
really
fast. Just make sure it actually still
runs with the uh original mini batch
size trains.
it? That's not good at
all. How the heck did I break it just in
the process of doing this?
on. Like
really? Oh, batch size.
Yep. That's the original curve right
there. Perfect.
Okay, that eliminates name
space. Now we want to do is continuous,
hidden size, RNN, all that stuff.
So for is
LF is
discrete.
Yes, this is all correct.
size policy hidden size. This is allowed
because
uh LSTM will have
this back end agents per batch doesn't
exist in native ends.
So that should hopefully fix some stuff
as well.
action. What is the correct way to do
this?
You clip in the environment, I guess,
right? The Ven has to clip
it.
No, you have to clip in clean paparel, I
think. Right.
Actually, we can do this a little
easier, can't
we? If I just go up
here and
then pumping
It's something like
that. We have to test that. Of
course. We do like Can we do like
continuous breakout or something?
It
runs. Doesn't train anywhere near as
well. Might need totally different
prams, but it runs.
um not really
needed API warnings.
working on Super Mario
Land. fun.
We should probably figure out how to
bulletproof the end of API a little bit,
huh?
For some reason, it doesn't feel like
I'm ready to
quite What are like the other things?
Like it seems like there's an out of
order issue
happening. Not really. I should just be
able to do that, right?
arcs. Oh, wait. Is frame skip set to
four in this? I did not realize
that. Well, that right there is where
our perk difference is coming from. I
Okay, so this just doesn't freaking do
anything.
Your unpack here is supposed to actually
do
something. I didn't pass ram skip.
How is this supposed to uh do error
checking?
So, uh I mean this just
like
happily chugs
through. Oh,
wait. Hang on. Maybe this is the wrong
one.
Oh, that's so bad
though. We don't want to allow optional
I'd way rather not
support
optional
arguments from Python to C then make it
ever possible to do that, right?
Is that
true? Let me
think. Hey, bet. How's it going?
I'm just trying to figure out if like I
can either support optional
arguments, but like you're kind of
screwed on the C side if you set them up
wrong or it can just not support
optional arguments to
Yeah, I was just about to say, how do
you keep getting sick? But all right,
you have kids. Yeah, rip.
Yeah, this is end binding. So basically
what's happening right now is
um it's set up so that you can
pass optional
arguments like you can just pass
arbitrary optional keywords.
Uh, but the problem
on. No, this is still totally fine. You
can still do optional arguments. Yeah,
there's literally no trade-off here. I
was just
dumb. Okay, this is fine.
That was just straight up dumb. That was
just a bad decision.
Not
build.
Oh, double as expected. And binding.h.
H.
one. Yeah, we're not macroing
this. We're just not
There we go.
I don't know if this is a correct trace
back.
errors. Well, it's not as nice of a
trace back as you would like as the
thing like it should be down here as a
type error.
Well, you can get nice trace backs. You
just have to do them like you have to
return errors correctly.
Can I check? Is there a way to set check
if an error is set?
We can do pi error
occurred. If pi error occurred
Okay, so we're still
getting system
error. Why don't we just put the break
point on this function?
Oh, does that just not call this? Like,
am I
dumb? It'll rebuild if I just remove the
build file, obviously.
There we go. So, that's what we're going
for.
There you go. So that's what a correct
error is supposed to look like.
We can do something like
this. Now our test works correctly.
Oh.
Um, hang on. Shouldn't this like totally
screw
up? Oh,
yeah. There we go.
Perfect.
And now for missing
arg we'll do like
I don't
know. It's very
silly. Sometimes it's like you got to
them folks got to touch some grass, you
know?
What other stuff could we uh screw up
here? Reset.
Well, if you want to try to find stuff,
that would be
great. Yeah. So, this one here, this is
literally just missing the seed.
obs? So this still
segs it's likely on vex step.
fix. Yeah, that's harder to fix because
I'm just passing a pointer and usually
you don't even have the shape from C.
Let me actually let me do the easy ones
first, man. Like this is going to cover
most of the common
ones like immediately. Okay.
I got a random agent selection across n
number of maps working. Do I sweep from
here and see how good a policy I can get
across 512 maps or
whatever? Random selection and maps.
Do you have it so that you can have it
like give me 512 agents worth of maps,
right? Is that what you
have like I pick whatever number of
agents and we'll figure out how many M's
to
spawn. Yeah. So do that. Make sure that
the different processes or different
workers have like good seeds or whatever
so that they actually pick different
maps. And then like just go do a run of
we usually do like 20 48 double buffered
or you know however many buffers of
agents maybe like 8192 or 4096 total
agents whatever ends up
working. And then sweep that
Play with whatever workers get. Yep,
that's what you should
do. That is what you should
do. Hopefully that'll get you a very
nice driving policy in time for
Fancy new
puffer. 15 million step per second
pong. It maybe it takes 500 million
steps to solve pong, but who cares when
that's literally 30
seconds? 35 seconds for 500 million
steps.
32. Oh
yeah, D type checks,
huh? That's
tough. I want all of these things by the
way, B. Like, these are all helpful, but
I need to like let me finish the initial
type check stuff first and then I will
be able to respond to those.
Yeah. No, other people have hit that as
well. That is a good one to find.
and I will fix them. But you got to let
me write the I got to write the basic
ass tests here
first. Like this is one of the very few
things where it kind of actually makes
sense to have a test because if you
don't have one like you don't actually
get any error message. You just get seg
fault.
actions appears to be doing things but
isn't. Yeah. Um continuous doesn't train
out of the box. I don't know if you can
sweep it or not. I did play with uh
continuous breakout earlier today a
little bit.
Oh, I I did that one earlier today as
well. Bet it's So, if you specify a
different range instead of like negative
imp to in or whatever, uh it should now
clip for you.
fix. No, it doesn't auto flatten. Is it
supposed to?
I don't think it's supposed to auto
flatten. You'd have to describe that.
Let give me like four minutes or however
long it takes. I I'm going to finish
this. This is going to be quick. I'm
going to do a couple sets and then I
will I will gladly go through all of
these other things and like fix all of
those. Like save those. Don't like dump
those on me and forget about them.
I think this is I just didn't recompile
All right.
weird one log per m but you added per
log stuff which tried to index m
log
log of
i proving a debugging c. Um, well, I
mean, it's like I'm trying to make this
stuff error. Like I'm trying to make
this stuff more bulletproof, but it's
just it's a combination of things. Part
of it is working with the devs uh
version. Part of it is not having like
the clean docs on how to write an MV and
all the assumptions I make. Like, you
know, there's several things here.
one log
per we would really like to you know the
thing that I would really like to have
which we just I haven't figured out how
to do to do yet um is I'd like to be
able to like have just the uh end code
compiled with debug symbols so like you
can you should be able to get a full
stack trace basically when something
segs and it's just it's not always easy
to get the full trace through Python
even though you can set break points
from Python that's what I have to figure
Yeah, that script is meant for you to
not have to suffer just pure Python.
How the hell is this thing still
bolting?
reset. Ref count. Ref count split blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah.
step the
hell they didn't pass an
argument. There got to be some way to
like figure it out before this, Okay.
I
none. Is that
Okay. I could have sworn I freaking
tried that, but apparently not. My bad.
Actually, if I don't set this arrow,
what happens?
Okay. So, you have to you do have to set
the exception.
I used to have a lovehate relationship
with Python until I looked into the C
API. I can build some fast and really
cool. Yeah, I it's
like I don't really love the Python C
API itself. It's just like a lot of
boilerplate.
Um I I think the CAPI could probably be
better. It's nice that this at least I
can do this and it's not like mandatory
pi bind or something ridiculous.
But
um
yeah, I I guess practically like my best
case scenario would just be that like if
Torch had a C API, I would probably just
like jam some some Torch in Pure C and
be very happy with that. But given that
researchers like Python and everyone
likes Python and whatever, it's fine. I
don't dislike Python. It's just I wish I
could write more C and less Python.
All right, I'm going to use the
restroom. I'm going to be back in just a
minute or two and then we will uh if bet
if you're still here, we'll fix all
those remaining issues and then we'll
have nice clean end API. Users will stop
banging their heads against everything
and we will actually be able to do Okay,
cool. I got to use a restroom real
quick. I'm going to do a few
sets and uh then I will be right back.
syntax? Oh yeah.
Um, so not
actually. But the thing
is if you're not going to type defaf
destruct you better understand what a
type defaf you can but you'd actually
what you'd have to
like you'd have to do this would have to
be
defined and would have to be like
strruct breakout because if you don't
type def
then the type is not breakout, it's
strct
breakout. So
like you should just use the type defs
unless you understand what a type def
actually does,
right? Well, what would you have me
change it to though? because like I'm
not going to have it be struck by
default because then every single place
in your code that you want to type you
know env or whatever you have to type
struck
n wait you would I how would you not
realize this bet like you would have to
be you'd have to have your end not typed
deafed and you'd have to be typing
everywhere.
detect. I mean, I
like I'm trying to think how I would
test
this. Switching one. But the thing is,
you can't just switch one. Like that's
not even binding problem,
right? Like look, if I just go
here and I go to
breakout.h and I go I try to do
this,
right?
So this is not a puffer error, right?
This is not in the bindings.
C, right? Cuz you didn't define
breakout. You defined So like what would
you have me do? Because it's not like
this is in no way an error that comes
from the uh the end of binding or
anything that I've done, right? That's
just straight
up like you didn't know
C. Like, yeah, I hit that a bunch before
I learned what a type defaf does.
right? Oh, so you would just have me do
it like this. I could do
that, but you'd still need this. Like,
you'd still need the client up here
unless you move the client to the top.
What do you mean it
You might have gotten it with
Syon because there was actually a
problem with that with
Syon. Do you remember specifically with
the new
API? No, like Syon. Syon apparently has
some issues with type defs.
Well, the see the uh the client would
need a forward declare unless I move
it.
Well, isn't that it? I just
honest. Yes, it was training that fast.
Buffer is very fast.
mil. We'll
do I believe that you got issues and
that stuff was jank. I just don't know
it was like with Syon or something.
that
slow? What do you mean that's
All
right. family got here
early, but uh I
will I got another hour
20ish and then I will be out at
6 and then maybe back on later. Hey
bet. Welcome to all the YouTube folks.
Actually, great time to mention for all
the folks watching. All this stuff is
free and open source at puffer.ai. You
can see all our demos. you want to help
me out for free, just start the
repository. Really helps. If you want to
get involved with development, just join
the Discord. Most of our top
contributors came in with no RL
experience at all. And uh yeah, it's
pretty uh I'm not going to say easy, but
it's doable to pick up. So, you join
there and help us out and learn a bunch
of AI stuff and contribute to research
as well. Cool. Back to
this. Yeah, do start the puffer. It
helps us out a lot. Okay.
Um heartpole.py
Apply training app runs appears to be
functioning is actually silently
failing. I
see
his
Uh yeah, what are we what are we looking
at? And Aaron also wants to chat on
stuff. Um
That's so obnoxious. Default DT type for
numpad is float 64.
Yeah. Is it for torch as well?
I don't know. But I frequently see
actions for reason. So it could be
right. 32 and torch. So, numpai is just
insane. Freaking float 64 is default
type. Yeah, I'm not sure why.
Numpai does not want you to have pass
code.
So, I mean, I understand why this
happens, right? Like, you're passing a
buffer of the wrong data type. I just
don't know how the hell I check that,
right?
It goes through buffer somewhere,
doesn't it?
Um, I guess I can just explicitly say no
float 64s. That'll catch most issues,
right? True.
Oh, yeah. Okay. I think your audio is
just quiet. I'm too quiet. I'm I got
you. It's too It's too damn uh there. I
have I have a mixer on my end. Yeah,
just turn me up. I mean, mine's already
at max gain.
All
right, folks. Can tell me if that's
off. I've got a testing testing. Loud
bet. Quiet bet. Just just relatively
relatively reasonable bet, I think.
Great.
I think mine peaks more, but that's just
how I talk.
No, your your audio sounds great. It
better damn well sound great. This mic
and mic setup was not cheap.
Yeah, mine was. Well, you know, I bought
at the right price point, right?
Uh yeah, it's like a $500 mic.
There's no right price point.
Well, you're doing a little different
streaming. I mean, the only streaming I
have is Grock plays Pokemon. So, yeah,
I don't know. I figured I would just
upgrade the setup for the new facility.
I've got the uh the camera set up here
and everything. Sony ZV10. When you when
you leave, it autofocuses on the stuff
in the background, too, which is kind of
cool. Yeah, that's intentional.
The only thing is I have to occasionally
I don't like the um the default ISO on
it. So I occasionally like I I have to
like manually set the ISO, but
everything else is
fine.
Yeah. All right.
So actions.
Maybe there's a way to get the type out
of this.
I'm sure there is.
Okay. So, if I just go
here and finding
Who said no? Did I say no? I didn't say
anything. No, I mean like this. It
doesn't break. Yeah. No, it doesn't
break. That's why that's why I'm
messing. It doesn't break point.
Oh, is it not going through there?
It damn well should be.
Are we ever passing structured actions?
Uh, not with native events.
How do we not get
there? Bizarre.
Sorry. What? It just skipped over
actions.
Huh? How did it just skip this block of
code?
What? No, no, no. That's not how
programming
works. Oh, no. I'm dumb. I just Hang on.
I just missed it.
I can just do uh Hang on. Maybe this
will do
Let's see if this does
anything. So, what is it? Uh, can
cartpole.
Yeah, cartpole or I imagine any anything
that you need to explicitly pass.
So it's this space here. This thing or
this actions? I guess this actions. Why
is this even needed man? Not that. It's
that uh yeah the space self deductions
equals the init zero in it for self
deduction. This is supposed to get
initialized for you. It doesn't though
right here.
I'm saying that that knowing knowing to
put that line there is not not something
that people are going to know.
Well, this will just
break.
Like this is just wrong.
with what did you did you change
anything? No, that's just been wrong.
Like it's what's what's wrong about it?
Well, if you multipprocess this thing,
for instance, you're overwriting the uh
the buffer that's set by the that's set
by this.
It works.
You're training without
terminals. You're just training with uh
reward is my
guess. It's still technically wrong. You
got lucky, but it's wrong.
So, you're saying even even though there
are terminals, they're not working
or Well, yeah, they're not hooked up to
the buffer. You overwrote the buffer.
I should probably like defy and set
attribute to prevent you from doing
this. I don't know.
So it's just it's just lucky that the
functions. Yes.
So because look self.actions exists and
it's of type
int 32. Yeah, it's kind of weird.
But why? Let me go freaking figure it
out.
Perhaps that's why I have that line
there.
Huh? Why is your single action space
like
Is the default DT type for box like
screwy? That what we're dealing with
here? Default type for box should be
that actually 32 even though I have
explicitly declared it there. So it
doesn't really Okay, let's make sure
that that is the case. I remember asking
GPT on one of my runs.
I got a bad right knee at the moment.
It's pissing me off. That's That's
always a thing, Joseph. That's It's not
one thing. It's another thing. But yep,
the physical. Well, and I'm getting a
hot tub over here. That is That That
should be some good recovery.
Nice.
[ __ ] hot tub.
That's the one thing cuz I have one in
California and it just ah like the one
thing I actually will use. It's like the
one like good for recovery. It's like
the one like extra thing that I will
actually use and actually like that made
a huge difference training for my 50k as
well.
Yeah. No. Okay. Good for recovery. And
then everyone was like, eh, you got to
take like cold whatever cold plunge.
This is just like nope. Screw that.
Well, if you're going to do cold too,
you got to do hot cold. I I think you're
fine just doing hot. Worked. It worked
perfectly well.
So, if I just delete this. Yeah, delete
it. This will now work. But it'll it'll
work. For your case, I'm going to do
this. It It'll look like it's working,
but it's not working.
Hold
on. E. What? Float 64.
lib.py. There you
go. That's better, right?
Is it? Yeah, because now you get an
error.
Pass np.flow32 buffer. That's what you
wanted, right? You delete the line and
rerun.
Hold
on. Let me do it for both of these
before I
annoyingly. Okay. So, I'm going to
rebuild just to satisfy you here. Yes.
Although if you Oh, you touched the M
binding. So, yeah. Boom. This is a force
rebuild. Rebuilds everything. Yep. It
wasn't just me who had that issue, too,
by the way.
Now, you get this
error with
64. If I delete
missing keyword argument continuous but
first of all this is false by
default continuous is true right there
is it not
there you
So note that these are all good error
messages, right? Like those are all like
none of those are like jank backend
things. Those are all intentional
thought error messages. Now
what's happened here?
I don't know. But we actually get a
reasonable error.
These are the hardest to
do that. Feels like that could be fixed
in uh in Python.
kind of annoying. I just want I just
want to know how you fix it because I've
I've I've done this before.
Oh, this
I've done all this before. Well, because
this is because this is like very
obvious what's happening to me. Like I
just I know what's going on here. Like
it's just that it's taking the space of
action action space.shape and because
action space is a box um it actually has
a shape. If you take it discreet, this
will just be like an empty shape. So
you'll you'll collapse the last
dimension. But that doesn't happen with
a box. And that's just a difference in
the gymnasium API and it's really
annoying.
Yeah. The question is where do we where
where do we go to to fix it? Because it
seems like whenever I try to fix it, it
just flip-flops.
I mean, it's a choice. Like we have we
have choices here, right?
Oh, watch. Hey, no choices. Hey, yeah,
Aaron said no choices. Okay. Did you see
the results?
Cool results. We trained Paul at 15
million steps per second. Still have to
hear about that.
Nice. I'm
getting
89ish,000 steps per second. That's not
an amazing number of steps. That's like
a kind of suboptimal I would describe it
as number of steps per second. Really? I
would suggest increasing that,
you know. I I'll see what I can do. Oh,
difficult researcher.
Yeah. Um, so far, uh, it looks like LP
is making no difference with the new
stuff because we're saturating either
way. Yep. I mean, that's kind of what
happens when you saturate either way.
So, remember the stuff now where I said
it's time to make like some new
curriculum things and then run it over
that. Probably that coupled with making
Yeah, plus tiny boxes. We are in stream
by the way technically right now. That's
fine.
uh box there is a very very slight
performance gain
um in terms of like we shifted the code
we shifted the curve to the left a
little bit I mean but to be fair like
the general trend of this has been every
time we have an unoptimized baseline and
you run it yours does better and then
whenever we have an optimized baseline
it's like well okay they both work right
yep that's totally fine that's a fine
result which basically tells me that
like all the curriculum learning stuff
is good whenever you haven't done a
bunch of tuning.
Well, I mean I think it's also possible
here, right, that we
like I think it's possible that we make
like the harder distribution or whatever
or like we try to get to like try to
make it get to like way harder maps over
time. Um yeah, there could be something
to that.
There could definitely that
the maze agents are kind of crazy
though. Yeah, that was wild. We got
it's.9 on 40 on up to 48 by 48.
Nice. Kind of ridiculous.
Train fast. Can I use it for Gro plays
Pokemon? That's that's my only question.
You can use it to play Pokemon and I
guarantee you if you like retune stuff
with the latest puffer, you will beat
the current Pokemon Red.
I would we can probably solve the game
like several times faster now. I
wouldn't be surprised. You know, with an
L. I mean, just call whatever tool you
want. Okay. If I can convince it to call
the maze solving tool, that should be a
pretty pretty easy way through dungeons.
Yeah, maybe you'd have to make a map
that is like an exact port over from
that maze, but then uh literally made
part of the map. So, makes it perfect.
Yes, I have I have the I have the full
version of the Pokemon map. Yeah.
Um, yeah, there isn't a fix for this,
sadly.
No, it's not even my fault, though. It's
It's the It's the gymnasium API being
shitty.
I mean, hang on. Maybe let me try one
other thing.
Oh,
nope. I messed
up. Wait, how the hell did that
happen? The plastic is
NP. Squeeze.
Discord can technically mix stuff, but
I'm uh I mostly have to mix things
myself. The bet and Aaron are different.
Then I have to actually do that
separately.
Oh, on the stream. They completely are.
My bad.
Like Aaron, way the hell down.
Oh, is he super loud? Yeah. Mega Aaron.
Hey Aaron, how you doing?
I might have miked you down too much.
Perfect. No problem. Just shut me up. I
might have miked you down too much.
We'll try that. People can yell me up.
It's bad. Testing testing. Aaron,
testing testing testing one two. Joseph,
congratulations.
Oh, is that official or is it I haven't
gotten an email. Is it just
official? It is. Oh, cool. Well, I got I
got an email saying accept and uh so
has so has a few other people I know.
And then also if you go into open review
and go to the accepted pile, you're in
there. Oh, okay. Cool. Well, that's cool
news. Uh, yeah. Puffer Lib getting
published. Cool. Now, here's the
question. Are you coming back to Canada
after we almost killed you last time?
I'm considering it. Who's going to
present?
I'm considering
it. Like, I
should I have not run 1500 miles like
this year. Uh if I get that again to be
clear, uh this time it would kill me.
I'd just be dead.
Yeah. Yeah, you possibly would. Yeah,
I'm pretty damn sure. I cannot Well, I'm
getting back to decent enough shape. I'm
doing intervals at between 7 and 7:30
pace. So like four 1 kilometer intervals
on my interval day. I'm doing like
decent 10k on the weekend. Uh lifts are
way low, but that's mostly just because
I've been trying to be really careful
and not injure myself putting the
strength back on wise.
And I still have a screwed up knee
that's mostly from the freaking uh
Florida roads suck. Yeah, I have an
ankle sleeve and and a knee sleeve I
wear.
Are you going to just get yourself a
treadmill? H are awful or elliptical
then? No, [ __ ] that. I'm running out.
I'm I'm running outside at the moment.
Not on roads for the most part.
Oh, by the way, I found a very strange
bug in um your new puffer stuff, which
is when you pass in args, it's just
treating them all as strings.
Yeah. Yeah.
So, at the moment, that's not that's
Python, by the way. That's actually just
Python being [ __ ]
That's been there. It's just Python
sucks. I don't have to tell you. Well,
they wasn't treating them as strings
previously. I'm pretty sure it was
because I' I've noticed that for a
while. Like like passing them in where
the config. The thing is that config uh
the like config parser like Python's
loader for that. It just there's no
types on the bloody things. Those are
parsed as strings. No. Yeah, it's just
parsed to strings and I have to do an a
literally eval. That's always that's
always been the Yeah, arg parse can
usually just take it right.
Uh it's not arg the any files.
Ah, there we go. So arguably a few
things that I moved from arc parse to
any files might now be wrong.
If you if you want to do like an Omega
config uh PR, by all means, do
we don't use Omega comp for any of RM.
There isn't there isn't a one good
solution. We visited it before. Oh, I
know. I've tried these things before in
the past. I'm pretty sure everyone has.
Um I guess there's a hack I could do.
I just want to see it work at this
point. Uh just just curious if if you
can make it work. No, there's a hack I
can do.
Hack. No hack. Wait, no. I might have
been able to monkey patch it, but
I suppose I should go into the stream.
I mean, if you want to. I'm just trying
to like madly fix things.
Yeah. If you have any uh new binding uh
woes
or bugs you've noticed or
issues, now's the
time. I've got a list for him.
Honestly, I just tried not to uh think
about environment
things currently.
edit edit box. I'll probably remove the
assert.
Everything you everything works if you
just remove all all checks. Yeah, just
get rid of the checks.
Yeah, if it doesn't work, user error. I
do like that about Python. You just go
modify whatever source you
Hot select an access to squeeze out
which has size not equal to one.
If you want it perfectly flat, you can
use
flatten. Uh, I don't.
Okay. It's annoying cuz actions don't
match Jackson's
face. Can't flatten a box.
I don't
know. Watch me.
I'll take your 3D box and project it to
two dimensions. Take that flat land.
Yeah, exactly. Just just manually handle
it.
Uh, is it with new bindings or was is it
with old bindings?
boxing.
Okay. Is there anything crazy about the
logging
there or is it going to be easy for me
to refactor?
Oh, it's not
much. Uh just just if you have some
complicated uh like not terminal logging
stuff going on, then it's a little
trickier to
handle. One log perm. Okay. All right.
That's that's fine. That's that's that's
That's not new. Snake does that. Our
does that.
Uh, ENMO has that as well.
So, this
Shouldn't this be like easy and serial
at the very
least? Oh
[ __ ] Cereal does not help.
Uhhuh. I figured out what we're going to
do.
Like Jason, I don't think we're going to
be seeing Bert
uh in Puffer Lib in in the future at
all.
Probably. I'd be very surprised.
No, we don't. I I don't I think the name
alone disqualifies it.
I have uh this theory that all ML
researchers either got stuck at like age
four and naming things Elmo and Bert or
like age 14 and edgy as
Now, apparently Bert is the most
downloaded inker on Hugging Face. 68
million plus monthly.
Damn. Monthly.
Like, who's downloading that much?
was it supposed to train with
continuous?
Yeah, it it trains properly with both
discrete and continuous actions.
Sure. because you weren't passing
continuous correctly to it before. It
was It trains even better with
continuous if I dare say so myself. All
right. Well, it's not training right
now. Whoa. Is that Is that puffer
animation new? Yeah.
I got bored. Okay. Like I like that. I
got really bored. As if he didn't have
enough things he was doing. No, it's
good. But may maybe we get to go.
There's like three lines of code. Turn
right. Turn around and go the other way.
When it gets to one side, it can just
turn around and go back. You can't turn
the puffer around.
Is that some kind of Joseph's third
idiom? Puffer cannot be turned. Well,
it's it's literally true. It's an emoji.
Like, you can't flip emoji. I don't
think
I'm sure we can figure out how to flip
an emoji. If there's not a Unicode a way
to do it in Unicode, you just can't do
it.
Well, that's fun.
Yeah, emoji are directional as far as
I'm aware. Unless like there'd have to
be a way to render text backwards as
well, right? Uh, yeah, there is.
All right. Um, so this works. Um, I'm a
little bit suspicious of the art pole
working because like it doesn't seem to
work with continuous or discreet.
Is that was that a continuous breakout
policy there?
No, but it doesn't work for the street
either.
I mean, that score seems pretty high.
No. 854.
Well, Breakout works, but Cartpole
doesn't. No, that that's solved for
Breakout. that number. Mhm.
Um, pull should be going to
You can probably go check and see if I
broke anything, but I don't think that
what I just did would have
Well, put put put put back in my uh my
thing that I had in there. The the float
uh actions. I can check the DT type.
It's going to be float 32, though.
or in 32. If it's uh continuous is off.
Well, if it's an int, then that's that's
the wrong for
discreet. Isn't discreet supposed to be
an int?
Discreet is is a float in in purple.
Oh, well then yeah, you're going to have
to
Is it
float? Oh, it
h. Yeah, they're floats.
Action.
Oh,
yeah. Action.
I'm not doing
anything. Oh, no. There it is. Cool. And
train slower now,
the score is going up to It shouldn't be
able to Oh, wait. That's breakout.
Duh.
Uh, look, the car's going
instantly. And then what continuous true
is supposed to
solve? Boom. I solved that.
Well, something's weird there.
Something's weird with the continuous
now. All right. I may have broken
continuous. I'm giving you this to fix
while I chat with Aaron.
Wait, now it's solving.
right. Just like check the data that I'm
passing around and make sure it's
like that will fix the flatten thing
though.
There's there's there's more there's
more too. Whatever you're Well, I got to
chat with Aaron here. Yep. Do it. What's
up, Aaron?
Oh, not much. Just like I mentioned, the
LP stuff is all right. We can take look
at that.
No longer providing much, which is, as
we said, fine considering we optimized
for this this graph.
Uh yeah, this is LP the bright green
one. Yep. Yeah, this is
fine. That's a fine
result. Um I'm just running more at the
moment. Oh, small thing I noticed last
night. Yep.
Uh when I get to the end of training,
uh
the the function is just hanging.
So the sweep dot there's you have to
define sweep.metric
uh and it has to match the metric that
you want to use for
evaluation.
I'm I I didn't put this on sweep yet.
You still need the metric. So the way
the thing that it does it tries to get I
probably I should do something about
this. Let me add a
todo. So, here's the thing. Um, it's
going to try to run until it gets some
stats back on this the metric that you
tell it. So, if that metric doesn't
exist, then it just won't ever get it.
Gotcha. So, I think the default is like
score. So if you don't have score, then
you know it's just going to hang
forever.
Okay.
Yeah, that's the main issue. Is there
any way we can fix that ridiculous egg
vault? Like so I um the next things I
was about to start running was switching
back to multipprocessing and see if that
seg vault is still here with the push up
to release. Okay.
Uh, I imagine it is, but you know, also
maybe it's not. Yeah, I mean, we
definitely need to figure that thing out
because like the we need to be training
at reasonable speeds. Also, I I told you
I'm getting uh I think I told you I'm
getting tiny boxes, right? Yes. So,
we're going to have a 12 GPU
uh 12 GPUs to throw at things. Six per
box. Um, I'm hoping that this actually
motivates them to optimize their code
because like it's not gonna like it's
we're gonna cap out at two GPUs with the
way that their code is right now. Um,
honestly, we could probably cap out at
one maybe it does they end of bottleneck
pretty hard sometimes. Uh, it depends
how fast the cores are and neural MMO is
not going to bottleneck. Um, we're kind
of just going to full send that.
Um, also based on like recent stuff, I
do think it's quite possible to have
architectures that are like way faster
uh than some of the defaults that we
have now. Like I think we could get
neural MMO training at 1 to two million
steps per second, maybe even higher uh
on one GPU. So I think we could get over
10 mil optimized on
six. And I mean at that point you can we
can do trillion step like we can do
trillion step runs.
Damn. I think that that's I that might
be over the scale of Dota at that point,
right?
Like I actually don't remember what the
x-axis was on Dota, but it was big. It
was big. Uh I think that's probably
comparable to
uh the experience in Xland as well.
They they didn't have a trillion axis,
did they? Uh, so their axis itself
wasn't a trillion, but their whole thing
was population based.
Well, you split your experience over all
the I don't
know. Anyways, I think you just like
shred every and that would actually be
with a real policy. Like I think we can
do that with like a 512 hidden LSTM.
Oh, damn. Yeah. It turns out that the
convent encoder is just really slow. Um,
like I can get neural MMO to 1.8 million
steps per second without that con
encoder.
A con encoder should just be a single
matrix multiply though if they've set it
up right. I don't know. That's weird.
But anyways, like I think that with some
optimization it is possible. Now the
thing is I've kind of spent a ton of
time doing optimization. So I don't know
if that's going to be the immediate next
thing. Um, yeah. you really want this
damn update shipped already. Um it's
just it's been too long. Um yeah, so I'm
trying to just like fix all the little
things, get sweeps done, get like new
environments checked in with good
baselines, all that stuff, and then
we'll have the release which will be
either 25 or 30 depending on how good
the sweeps are. Um makes sense.
And yeah, then I it's going to be like
spend month on hard algorithms I think
which is right up your alley.
Yep. So we can do that and then I think
after that I come back and do Perf and
you know I find some time to like run a
company somewhere in the middle of those
two things. Um, speaking of which
though, like I think the results on like
the results that we've gotten from uh
from the sweeps have been pretty solid.
Like 2.5 in 300 mil in 10 minutes. Oh,
that's insane. Yeah. Like I was I was
looking at their curves the other day
just to get their Oh, we crushed them.
Yeah. So, I mean, it's kind of cool that
like this is kind of what I do when it's
like when you let me just do [ __ ] my way
and like you just like wait a while.
Eventually, I just like will come back
with something like this. So, I think
that they'll should be happy with that.
Um, but like I really have to be able to
do all the stuff the way I want to for
that to happen. Yeah. And you think
they'll be fine with LP being like, hey,
it worked in the unoptimized case and it
didn't really do much in the optimized
case. No, I think that what we should do
is we should now I think that you can
beat these current curves, but I think
that the way to do it is the thing that
we discussed originally where what you
should do is you should go look at some
of the variables in that config should
tie some of them together into like a
resource density or difficulty or
whatever. Okay. And then you should LP
that you only have like a couple like
dimensions if you will of scaling and
then you LP that.
Yeah. Uh
so
I tied together a bunch of the params
um and we are lping over that currently.
Oh, so that's already what this
experiment is. Yes. And let's see the
config that
here. Um the right place to grab this is
here.
So, I tied together uh shared resource
cool down uh generator cool down and
alter cool downs. Obviously, I can tie
together more things or break other
things apart.
Let me see what these are. So, there's
cooldowns. So the score should look very
different at low cool
right? If you set cool down to one, you
just immediately like the score should
go off the charts.
there, right, these
are pretty binary options right here.
It's either like 50 or 100 or 25 or 50.
We can blow that up,
add more things that way. So wait, this
is But like I'm confused with the curve
you sent me because is that an eval
curve? Like cuz the train curve should
look very different. Like with something
like this, if you're sampling zero cool
down, like the score for those maps
should be 100 or something like 100
hearts or something
ridiculous. So this is uh yeah, these
are the train curves on these samples. I
think their sampling probably is built
to not hit that lower bound of zero. So
that means it's just 50 or 100 or 25 or
50. And in those cases, I don't think
this is making a bunch of difference. I
think so. I haven't checked that in a
minute. Okay. I would look at that and
like make sure that this makes sense
because
Yeah. And it also should be more
granular because this really isn't
giving you a lot of curriculum at all.
Um al wait resource generator and alter.
So
like cool down and this is percent or
something. What is this?
You know, I never really fully
understood what that was. Whether it was
a percent or whether it was like a step
cool down. Isn't this because 50 or 100
is massive. That's a massive cool down.
Yeah. So wait, if this is supposed to be
zero cool down 50 or 100 like huh?
Well, I think it's just 50 or 100. I
think that zero is but like the cool
down is the original cool downs. Weren't
they way lower than that?
No, no. The I I took the original
cooldown which have sampling
050 and just tied them together and
moved them up.
Have sampling. Oh, because their
original domain randomization had this.
Yes. Okay.
So, if you scroll a little bit further
down,
um, let me just tell you which Yeah, I
ran my baseline. I that I beat their
domain one. Like, I just ran it on their
default. I doesn't even have domain
randomization.
Yeah. So, uh if you look at the laser
um option on that one, I didn't tie it
in there. And so, that's an example of
the alter cool down one. And that's how
they set it up in there as well. So, the
rest of these were just matched to that.
So, is that just like 10 or 20?
Again, I believe so. I haven't actually
been uh sure on
that. But there are other things, right,
that we can also tie together like tie
together health for
instance. They're immortal right now,
aren't they,
though? Okay. So, the cool downs are
actually 50 or 20. I
see. Yeah.
Yeah, I don't understand the eval curves
then. Oh, wait. Actually, maybe I
do cuz wait cuz basically this says then
that like let's say half your maps end
up at like 50 and half end up at 100.
You either have the normal difficulty or
ridiculously
hard.
Correct. So LP should stop sampling
stuff when it learns fully,
right? Uh unless you start forgetting
and then it will start resampling that.
So I think we want to go lower and
higher maybe.
Um sure.
And then I we should also verify this is
doing anything. Like it's probably not
it's very suspicious to me that those
curves are on top of each other
basically when um like 100 is a way
harder end. So like is it actually
solving harder M's or is something free?
So I keep track of all of the Ms. Uh
curves on all the individual M's as well
and they're all going up. It's solving.
Are they comparable? Like are there some
like with the hundreds that are like way
like lower or
um let me check real quick. I think
they're
all just sort of similar in scale and
scope. Well, they shouldn't be because
there's a massive difference in
difficulty.
Like the curve should not even be close.
I'm a little
suspicious. Like is this getting applied
correctly? If it's not getting applied
correctly, that's some problem with how
their stuff handles it then
because this was supposed to integrate.
I wouldn't be surprised if they like I
would not assume that they have correct
stuff there.
Like you should definitely like load up
some maps and look at them. Yeah.
Cool. Mhm. Yeah. I'll make these more
granular and like make go sanity check
some stuff like watch like go like
update or at least like like load up the
end watch them see if like these
actually seem to be doing anything. Um
yeah, you can also like these are just
cool downs, right? This doesn't even
mess with like the number that are on
the map.
Correct. That's a big one like
density, general density. That would be
a good one to do, right?
But I would try to have like some I'd
just have like a variable that's like
cool down that just like multiplies all
the cool downs, right? I would have a
variable that's like no density that
multiplies all the
densities and like maybe that's it
agents maybe
you could do number of agents. Sure. But
oh uh maybe maybe not because that's not
going to be fun vectorization wise.
Okay. Yeah, that's not going to be fun
to do with vectorization.
I'd keep the agent and then like make
sure it's actually doing what you think
like loaded up the renderer that type of
thing. I will say there is no density
argument in their YAML.
No, you what you'd have to do is I guess
is it a total pain to like overwrite
stuff in their config once they loaded
or no? Because like what I would do is
right like you'd sample their stuff.
Okay. Like you would just sample a
density and then just set all the like
multiply all of the the base values by
that density.
Sure.
That's probably what I would go for. And
like Yeah. I mean I think the thing for
you is like see if you can get them see
if you can get them some cool LP result,
right?
Like I think that like if you can show
it like if you can show it like working
on harder maps or something that like
maybe if I train on those like if I just
train on the originals like it doesn't
work on those maps or something like if
you can show some some like you're just
trying to show like some cool new
learning with LP and like it seems like
it should be doable because your curves
have been consistently on top of all the
unoptimized ones. So it seems like it's
just waiting for the opportunity, right?
Yeah. All right, cool. So, I will Yeah,
I'll start tearing apart their things
and sort of find a setting that breaks
them. Yeah, that would be that'd be a
good that would be a good start. Yeah, I
mean, you can even do this type of thing
you did with the mazes before, right?
Where like most of the M's are hard and
some of them aren't.
Yeah, it's a little bit
um Yes, I can set up something like
that. Hardest high hardest high cool
down in like a resource or whatever or
like a few resources.
Yep. Or I could even just like push down
things like some of these reward values.
Uh
I lowering rewards to make things harder
is kind of artificial. I would say you
kind of want to have like you want
optimized rewards for whatever the
problem is. I would think
typically. Yeah. Yeah. Because it's like
the the goal here is practical use like
something practical, right? So like if
you can show like the thing working on
like harder distributions or something
like that would be cool because the idea
here is that you don't actually know
what's a hard map and what's an easy
map. And like maybe they just don't have
a lot of variety in their PCG right now,
right? Like I'd be willing to bet that's
the case. It's like neural MMO. You
probably won't get much by randomizing
maps on neural MMO alone cuz like the
maps are big and all the diversity that
you're going to see is pretty much
already in one big map.
That makes sense. I think it's probably
something similar where like if you want
to actually get something out of LP, you
need to make the maps meaningfully
different. And that means like cool down
difference, that means like resource
density difference. You're actually
going to have to like mess with some
stuff to get that to work.
Sounds good. And then make sure when you
load it up that you actually are seeing
like low density, high density maps and
stuff. Cool. Cool. Thanks, Aaron.
Bye bye. Joseph, how do you run training
in in in the release branch puffer?
So I thought cannot import name C from
puffer lib. Uh you have to compile that
I hit the other day. Yeah. So you have
to there's so be the thing with that.
Let me show you. It's really annoying. I
have to fix this. It's just going to
take me a while. So install or no. So
this C extensions you build with this.
Okay. And then you change this to torch
extensions and uncomment this command
class and you build again.
Yeah, my bad. You only have to do this
once though and then it'll have the
kernel. But you need to have it built
this way for the kernel. And the thing
is you can't have it do both because
this command class will break this e
compilation.
All right. Anything else for me to
check? Bet. There's more stuff.
Uh float check for logs. Do you have a
float
check or that one? I actually
legitimately don't know how I would do.
And you just check them in
uh binding.
I can't introspect the type of the of
the strct as far as I'm aware.
I can cast to a float. That would be
decent enough.
Yeah, that doesn't fix it. It kind of
fixes it a little bit. Break
differently. Uh, it'll be harder to
break it at least. Well, I mean, if
you're using an is you're going to be
using maybe an int accidentally, but if
you're casting to a float, it's not
necessarily going to be I think I
already did this here.
Well, I know there's a comment in there
right there. Iterates over logs one
float at a time will break horribly if
log has a non-flow data. But that's
assuming people read comments. Well, it
actually
So technically, if you have an int, it
wouldn't break. It'll only break if you
have a different size
type cuz it's literally it's iterating
over the bites in the log. You see?
Yeah, I feel like it's a it's a
potential pitfall.
It absolutely is, but like what do I do
about it? I don't know.
There's no way for me to check the types
that you have in your log.
I can document this for sure. Like I can
make a onepage doc thing in the new, you
know, how to make a puffer
end. I have to think about that one. But
you see the issue though, right? can't
like I can't introspect the types of a
strruct in
C as far as I'm aware.
No, I don't I don't think I don't think
you're able to either.
I did put that cast in there though on
the float so that at least it should
average. But I hopefully if you define
it as an int, it's still four bytes. So
you should be okay.
If you put like a char or something,
you're screwed.
You're right. Of course.
Um, I thought ins were 16 bytes. No
bits.
Ins are four bytes, 32 bits. Short is 16
bits. Two
I like building things. Yeah, I mean
there are Yeah, there are the two PRs
that I have open. Yes. Oh, perfect.
Uh, I will go take a quick look. I don't
know if I have time to do full merges
right now, though, because I got to get
dinner. I may be able to come back after
dinner for a bit though and do those.
Sure, we could do it after or or
whenever is next,
but we're gonna have to get those uh
taken care of at some point um and
tested too. Like I was just running our
wasn't working. Uh, but I can't tell if
it's if it's a local
hardware versus box hardware issue or if
it is a uh which I
this works right there. There's uh local
triple try newbind dev and then the
local snake.
Yeah, look at the files change. Yeah,
not the commits because the commits
makes it look like I've put in a bunch
of uh crap in the M finding which I have
not
done. Yeah. So, that's a clean one. I I
am going to have to do like a a jank
thing when I merge because I'm going to
have to merge the uh the release branch
back in. So, I might wait to merge these
until then. I do I have to merge the
release branch in.
[Music]
Yeah. Or I have to pull these into
release branch alternatively.
Cool. Thank you though. These look good.
We will I mean these will get into the
release. It's just a matter of like when
I move things together. Yep. You're
welcome. I assume that you're just
merging things or putting things. Well,
it's just I've sliced and diced
literally everything. Um like you can
see here the clean puffl files
completely. Yes, I can see. Uh so first
of all, we're at 880 actual lines for
everything. Wild. Where did all the
lines go? me aggressively like pruning
and optimizing stuff. Can you explain
the 15 million SPS real quick?
Uh yeah, 5090 is happy with very large
uh very large mini batch sizes for small
networks and very large batch sizes.
Super mega batch. How how big how big of
a batch fits on these? I think I did
like 4 million batch 130k mini batch or
something with like 32 or 64,000 ends.
Damn. But the crazy thing is it actually
trained like Pong actually trained with
default params on that in 30 like 35
seconds I think. So like not even
optimized params hypers at all for that
new scale. 35 seconds 500 million steps
but 35 seconds if you have the mini
bats. Uh, if you have the mini batch
small enough, usually it works even with
a massive batch. If you get the mini
batch too big, you get speed, but you
get also not training. But this time it
worked with 131k.
131k mini batch. Yes, that's the crazy
thing. That's a batch, my guy. That's
not a mini batch anymore.
What's that, Aaron? That's not a mini
batch anymore. Yeah,
exactly. That's uh pretty pretty wild.
Uh, that's good.
Um, we're if we're going to get Dota
Dota numbers though, shouldn't we be
getting Dota
results? Uh, we are starting to get some
crazy
results building anything hard. I mean,
if you think you got a giant llmmy mess
is is hard, then
yes, all of them are kind of obvious
obvious cell phone.
Yep.
All
right, cool.
Um, I'm going to go run over to
dinner since my family's here. Uh, and
then I'm going to see if I probably
should be able to just be back after
dinner. depends how I'm feeling. But get
another good work in. I'm trying to
think though because I can't really
merge these.
Let's just check real quick on our
sweep. Did this fail?
Think this
anything. Okay. So, uh, for the folks
watching at the moment, I will see if
I'm back after dinner. Get a few more
things done. That's how it's going.
Buffer.ai for all the things. It's all
free and open source code. Want to help
me out for free? Start the repo. If you
want to get involved with dev, join the
Discord and also follow me on X for more
RL content. So thanks and